los demócratas de la cámara pueden
elegir cuándo enviar su resolución de
acusación al senado el líder de la
mayoría demócrata de la cámara de
representantes steny hoyer dice que
tiene la esperanza de que esté sea
enviado pronto una vez recibido la
cámara alta debe comenzar un juicio sin
retraso sin embargo el senado controlado
por los republicanos está en periodo de
receso hasta el 19 de enero es decir un
día antes de que yo bailen asuma el
poder y el deber de la mayoría del
senado mitch mcconnell dice que no
volverá a convocar sesiones antes de esa
fecha así que el juicio del senado no
empezará hasta que don action vaya
dejado el cargo el presidente de la
corte suprema- presidirá el juicio nueve
fiscales nombrados por la presidenta de
la cámara nancy pelosi serán encargados
de procesar el caso que aún no ha
comunicado cómo se compondrá su equipo
de defensa una vez que el juicio termine
se necesita una mayoría de dos tercios
de los senadores para condenar a carlos
para entonces será demasiado tarde y
para hoy
de su cargo pero otros castigos podrían
ser votados
parece ilógico que se puede impugnar y
destituir a alguien si ya no está en el
cargo la destitución parece ser el
principal objetivo de la impugnación sin
embargo mirando la historia existe lo
que yo llamo una impugnación tardía
incluso después de haber dejado el cargo
existe la posibilidad de que lo condenen
por el recurso de descalificación
si el senado condena podría en efecto
decidir hacer una votación posterior
para descalificarlo en futuros cargos
políticos y ese voto sólo requiere una
mayoría simple para ser aprobado por
ahora algunos senadores republicanos en
ruptura con sanz han dicho que
considerarán el artículo de acusación en
su contra pero al menos 17 republicanos
tendrían que unirse a los demócratas
para alcanzar el umbral necesario de dos
tercios para condenarlo haciendo que la
sentencia sea poco probable